now our friend with the hair says that
working should not be a necessity Free
Housing free health care shouldn't be a
pipe dream he says that there should be
a universal housing Universal Health
Care we should be given all the food
that we need to eat all right so who
exactly is building the houses that we
are living in good question good
question who is cultivating the food
who's providing the medical care you
could say well the government will do it
the government is not a genie that can
make things materialize out of thin air
the government can only hire or more
likely conscript other people to build
the homes and harvest the food and so on
what this means is I'm constantly having
to remind the younger generation and my
own generation is that no matter what
happens no matter what system is in
place someone lots of people have to
work in order to keep all of society
afloat and all of the many mouths
including your own fed